The Walking Dead's tenth season finale
puts the spotlight on one of the
show's most notorious villains:
Negan, and it's full of surprises. Here's
how the episode plays out, and what it means.
The episode begins as Negan is exiled from the
community he helped save. He's given a cozy
little house outside of town, and asked to not
return. While dealing with this unexpected exile,
Negan has a vision of himself in the past,
as the Negan we meet at the end of season 6.
The presence of this previous version of
himself implies that, while he's clearly
changed a bit since he was defeated and locked
away, parts of his old self are still there.
Past-Negan chides present-day-Negan for trying
to win over the Alexandrians by playing nice.
"It's time to face the facts, old
man. You are nothing without her."
The "her" here refers to Lucille, Negan's
trusty baseball bat. But, of course,
it also refers to Lucille, Negan's
wife, and the namesake of the bat.
Negan appears disturbed by
the vision, but the next day,
he goes to the tree where he believes
his bat was buried after his showdown
with Rick in season 8. This is when we get our
first flashback, to twelve years in the past.
Negan is tied to a chair and a gang leader
called Baxter is interrogating him about
where he found his supply of chemo drugs, which
is somewhat of a rarity in the post-apocalypse.
It's clear that this Negan isn't the one we've
come to know later on. He's less self-assured,
has a hard time killing walkers, and doesn't
quite have that swagger that has come to
define his character. Negan begins to tell
the story of how he got the chemo drugs.
The drugs Negan is carrying came from a mobile
medical clinic. In a flashback, he makes a feeble
attempt to rob the clinic's doctors, but someone
with a baseball bat quickly knocks him out.
Eagle-eyed viewers will recognize his attacker as
Laura, who later becomes one of his most trusted
allies in The Saviors. When Negan comes to,
he tells Franklin, the head of the operation,
the story of why he needs the drugs,
which begins flashback number three.
Six weeks further into the past,
in the early days of the outbreak,
Negan is living with his wife Lucille,
who's undergoing chemotherapy. Negan is
an attentive and loving husband. However,
they're quickly running out of supplies,
and even though Lucille only has a few rounds
of chemo left, their remaining stash of drugs
spoils during a fridge malfunction,
forcing him to rob the medical clinic.
When Negan finishes telling his story,
they're remarkably generous and kind to him.
They feed him and give him the drugs he needs,
telling him they only want to help people.
Negan seems genuinely moved by their generosity.
Thanks to these cascading flashbacks, fans
can finally see aspects of Negan's personality
that were buried in the years that followed. He's
more vulnerable, without allies, real weapons,
or survival skills, and it changes
how he interacts with the world.
As Negan is leaving the clinic, Laura
gives him the familiar baseball bat
they'd previously used to knock him
out. But there are even more flashbacks;
in the midst of the scenes detailing Lucille's
chemo troubles, we're taken back to the earliest
days of the outbreak. It also introduces a
different moment in Negan's personal growth.
Pre-collapse Negan, as it turns out,
is a bit of a lout. He loses his job as a
gym teacher after beating someone up, and
he's spending his days playing video games. He's
also cheating on Lucille with one of her friends,
something that prevents him from being with her
when she first receives her cancer diagnosis.
It's pretty clear how much Lucille's
cancer changed Negan — or, rather,
how much his love for Lucille changed
him. Later, Negan weeps while Lucille
recounts how she learned about his affair,
but she tells him that she forgives him.
"I want you to know that you made up for it."
The episode demonstrates just how transformative
those emotions were for him during the earliest
days of the apocalypse, so how did he
then go on to become the Negan we know?
Back in the first flashback, Negan is
desperate to bring the chemo drugs he's
carrying back to Lucille, so he gives
up the location of the mobile clinic.
After the gang rounds up the
doctors, they let Negan go.
Lucille had previously begged Negan
to forget trying to save her life,
and instead just stay with her until she
died. When he finally arrives back at
home with the drugs, Negan discovers that
he should have listened to her. Lucille,
now a walker, is on the bed in their room.
She appears to have purposefully overdosed
on pills and tied one arm to the headboard
to prevent her from later attacking Negan.
Written on the door is a harrowing
phrase: "Please don't leave me like this."
It's a crushing moment for Negan, who's spent the
entire apocalypse trying to keep Lucille alive.
After sitting with her for a while,
he goes outside to a nearby fence
and uses some barbed wire to put the
final touches on Lucille the bat.
Once he's said goodbye to Lucille
the person, he burns down the house.
Back at the gang hideout, Franklin
is being tortured for information
about where he gets his medical
supplies from. Negan puts a stop
to it by killing most of the gang
members, but leaving Baxter alive.
It's here where viewers get their
first glimpse of the Negan they know.
Dressed in his signature leather
jacket and brandishing his bat Lucille,
Negan tells Baxter about the man he beat up who
got him fired. But now, the rules have changed.
"Now, when I see red, it's just a
question of what I am capable of."
Back in the present day, Negan digs up Lucille the
bat and brings it home to his cabin. He speaks to
it as though it's Lucille herself, apologizing for
leaving her, and even apologizing for naming his
baseball bat after her. Negan then places Lucille
the bat into his fireplace and watches it burn.
But things aren't quite that cut and dry. The
next day, Negan strolls back into Alexandria.
When Carol confronts him, he tells her that
he's not interested in living in exile.
Carol says that Maggie will kill him if
he moves back, and makes it clear that now
that she's tried to help Negan, she won't
intervene. Negan agrees and continues on,
looking at an infuriated Maggie as he walks by.
The mischievous grin he wears while he observes
her suggests that Negan's new chapter
won't necessarily include peacemaking.
Based on how season 10 ends, it feels inevitable
that the conflict between Maggie and Negan will
boil over very soon — and that it won't be
pretty. While Negan's past reveals that he's
a complex character and that his propensity for
violence is just one facet of his personality,
it also demonstrates that violence is
something that has always existed within him,
even if it's hidden under the surface.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
The Walking Dead are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.